el Estado Mayor central la principal
disidencia de las fuerzas armadas
revolucionarias de Colombia FARC anunció
su compromiso con la propuesta de paz
total del presidente Gustavo Petro en
nuestro empeño hacia la paz con justicia
Social es sincero es real todas nuestras
unidades en esta en este momento
ratificaron esa voluntad expresaron esa
voluntad para con el pueblo estas son
imágenes inéditas del grupo guerrillero
comandado por alias y van mordisco a
quien el expresidente colombiano Iván
Duque había dado por muerto es aquí en
los Llanos del yarí un lugar simbólico
de la historia guerrillera donde el
Estado Mayor central se reunirá para
discutir los avances en el proceso de
paz
el resultado de la reunión en la que no
participará el gobierno será un
comunicado la opinión pública y se
espera que se dé una fecha tentativa
para abrir la mesa de negociación
el sábado el grupo adelantó su propuesta
de realizar las conversaciones en
Noruega
la cita de este domingo llega luego de
varios meses de acercamientos entre el
alto comisionado para la paz Danilo
Rueda y el Estado Mayor central y
representa el inicio de la segunda fase
de la propuesta de paz total del
presidente colombiano con el inicio de
conversaciones con el Estado Mayor
central Prácticamente la mitad de las
personas hoy en armas entran en
negociación con el gobierno esta
guerrilla disidente el proceso de paz
entre el estado colombiano y las
extintas Farc en 2016 cuenta con al
menos 3000 hombres y opera
principalmente en la amazonía colombiana
la costa pacífica y la frontera con
Venezuela